this video is sponsored by the book
summary and Discovery app blankest
at the foot of Mount podisa there was a
small Forest where there lived animals
of all types one of which was a hair
being one of if not the fastest animal
in a forest that coveted speed the hair
was by far one of the most successful
and popular one of the least was the
tortoise he was not fast successful or
very popular at all
over time the Hair Success in popularity
had caused him to become incredibly
arrogant and he was often harsh and
contemptuous toward other animals
especially the tortoise he often scolded
and ridiculed the tortoise whenever he
saw him saying things like why don't you
get off your ass and actually get
something done or the truth is you're
just lazy the forest doesn't owe you
anything if you want to be fast you have
to work for it that's what I did or look
at you seems like nobody wants to be
fast these days why don't you pull
yourself up by your Pock Claws and get
moving
the tortoise was mostly unfazed by this
sort of stuff but it did mildly annoy
him especially whenever he saw the hair
saying the same sorts of things to other
animals
one day the tortoise had enough when he
saw the hair lecturing a porcupine about
how other animals never got close with
him because of his horrible attitude
[Music]
foreign
the hair loved to race everyone knew
this he regularly challenged other
animals and he always won any chance he
had to prove and perform his superiority
he happily indulged on this day however
the tortoise challenged the hair the
hair was dumbfounded you want to race me
the hair said laughing profusely yeah
the tortoise set back with a straight
face
after some more laughter the hair of
course agreed and the event was planned
for that evening the fox and some of the
other animals began preparing and
clearing the race path The Tortoise and
the Hare waited by the starting line
after a few moments passed the tortoise
looked at the hair and said say how did
you get so fast anyway the hair looked
at the tortoise with the confused look
on his face
because unlike most animals I actually
put in the work I run almost every day
hmm said the tortoise why do you do that
the hair paused for a moment because
because I understand the value of hard
work and being fast and I'm diligent and
disciplined about it
wow said the tortoise pausing for a
moment how do you understand all that
though
why are you asking stupid questions the
hair quickly said slightly annoyed you
know you can't suddenly become Faster by
asking questions right I'm just
interested in your story is All The
Tortoise assured the hair the hair never
gave up a chance to stroke his own ego
and so he quickly continued okay well I
guess that's just the way I am and how
my brain works and I also learned it for
my parents my dad was fast not as fast
as me but he taught me from a young age
The Importance of Being fast and how you
have to make sacrifices to get faster
and faster he taught me my
self-discipline and focus gave me my
work ethic he worked so hard to make
sure I had as many opportunities as
possible to practice and get better
huh said the tortoise what made him do
all that do you think how was he even
able to well because he worked hard too
and made a bunch of sacrifices himself
to become as fast as he could and live a
life that allowed him to spend time
teaching me those same lessons
wow said the tortoise but what made him
that way I don't know his dad what about
him replied the tortoise what about him
what made him that way I don't know his
genes being a hair being a hair during a
time when those sorts of things were
necessary for survival
the hair paused the two were quiet for a
moment well if he was like that because
he was a hair and a hair during that
time what made him a hair during that
time
the tortoise asked holy the hair
said before answering for 10 more
minutes the tortoise continued asking
the hair questions prodding further and
further into the past deeper and deeper
into the explanation of the hair speed
finally the hair reached the beginning
of everything with no more causes and no
more explanations left
so said the tortoise you're fast because
you were born a hair a particular kind
of hair and experienced a particular
kind of life but that's only because of
your parents how your parents lives were
and where and when they had you but all
that was only because of their parents
and how they were and where and when
they were all the way back to the first
hairs in history but there are only
hairs in history at all because life
operates through Evolution and ancient
lagomorphs made it and created the first
hairs but that only happened because
life started at all which only happened
because the right conditions developed
on Earth but of course Earth only came
to exist because of billions of years of
Prior Cosmic events which all only
happened because the Big Bang occurred
and time and space unfolded in a
particular manner so I guess technically
you're fast because the Big Bang
occurred and time and space unfolded in
a particular manner
huh
the hair stared at the ground with
widened eyes and tensed muscles
throughout his body and face he was
confused but not because he didn't
understand
what what about me though the hair said
looking up trying to hold on to his
lifetime worth of delusions of course I
made the difference I chose to do what I
did with everything that's happened to
me
how replied the tortoise how if you
didn't choose anything that's happened
to you did you choose that free will the
hair said less confidently it's one of
the main things that makes us hairs
different from everything else
okay but if everything that has happened
to you made you who you are but you
didn't control or choose any of what
happened to you how do you control who
you are the tortoise responded the hair
fell backwards onto his back laying in
the grass
soon The Fox re-emerged from the now
cleared race path he approached the hair
and tortoise and got into position he
counted down
the tortoise took off the hair stayed
laying in the grass what are you doing
the fox yelled the race started get up
the hair didn't say anything rolling
over onto his side
slowly but steadily the tortoise made
his way down the race path and
eventually passed the Finish Line
winning the race
after a celebration with some of the
other animals The Tortoise returned to
the starting line the hair was lying
flat on his back looking up at the sky
the tortoise approached him I don't
understand the hair said without moving
his body what replied the tortoise why
did you even challenge me to the race
isn't it all pointless win or lose it
wasn't really because of you at least
not in the way that it feels like it is
it's basically all just because of
arbitrary chance I'm fast because I'm
lucky
the hair rolled over onto his side the
tortoise moved a bit closer feeling a
little bad for him yes all that's true
said the tortoise being fast smart
successful it's not just hard work even
if it's directly a product of hard work
it's chance even being someone who works
hard is itself a product of chance
but working hard and doing what you're
meant to do is still necessary
you still have to run to be fast and
being fast is still useful
we're all just Pawns in the universe's
sick game tricked into carrying out its
grunt work when you don't realize this
you act like a real peacock but it's a
useful delusion to believe that you are
in control of your life you have to know
that you have no free will but live as
if you do
the Taurus concluded
the hair lay in silence for a moment
then he jumped back up to his feet
alright rematch then
the hair said
this video was sponsored by blinkist
discussing Free Will German philosopher
Arthur schopenhauer wrote let us imagine
a man who while standing on the street
would say to himself it is six o'clock
in the evening the working day is over
now I can go for a walk or I can go to
the club I can also climb up the tower
to see the sunset all of this is
strictly up to me in this I have
complete freedom but still I shall do
none of these things but with just as
free a will I shall go home to my wife
this is exactly as if water spoke to
itself I can make high waves yes in the
sea during a storm I can Rush down a
hill yes in the riverbed I can plunge
down foaming and gushing yes in the
waterfall I can finally boil away and
disappear yes at a certain temperature
but I am doing none of these things now
and involuntarily remaining quiet in
Clear Water in the reflecting pond
this was written in the 1830s nearly two
centuries ago although we have made
incredible strides in recent time toward
closer and clearer understandings about
our nature and reality classic
philosophical work from hundreds and
thousands of years ago remain incredibly
relevant and important to today blinkus
is an app that makes it easy to discover
sift through and learn from some of the
most important classic works of
philosophy it works by providing around
15-minute explainers and breakdowns that
can be both read and listened to even
while offline Linkus has titles from
thinkers like schopenhauer Friedrich
Nietzsche Emmanuel Kant Renee Descartes
Simone de bevoir loud Sue Seneca and so
much more of course blinkist also has
major contemporary non-fiction as well
spanning over 5 500 non-fiction books
and podcasts and over 27 different
categories covering anything from
physics to psychology to finance to
physical health and so much more and
through blink is connect premium users
can also share their account with one
other person and no additional cost
allowing you to share your favorites
selected books with someone close use
the link in the description or scan the
QR code on the screen and you'll receive
two memberships for the price of one a
seven day free trial and 25 off blank is
premium
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video